so you guys probably heard about this
whole Mozilla Firefox CEO fallout
situation Brendan Eich is the CEO or was
the CEO of Mozilla until last week he
donated a thousand dollars to prop 8 in
2008 the bad side of prop 8 and then
okcupid found out about this and they
blocked their site okcupid on the
Mozilla Firefox browser hello there
Mozilla Firefox user part of this
interruption of your okcupid experience
mozillas new CEO Brendan Eich is an
opponent of equal rights for gay couples
we would therefore prefer that our users
not use mozilla software to access
okcupid ok so then of course this blowed
up into a blue up into a giant firestorm
he stepped down uh but now it turns out
that there might be a little hypocrisy
here because the CEO of okcupid has
donated money to uh to some things that
perhaps he's not so proud of now ok
Cubans founder and CEO sam yagan made a
five hundred dollar donation to a
congressional candidate who oppose
same-sex marriage voted against the ban
on sexual orientation based job
discrimination and for prohibition of
gay adoptions records show that llega
who's also the CEO of match.com donated
five hundred dollars to representative
chris cannon his republican in utah in
2004 um so before we get to the
hypocrisy for this guy uh were you guys
happy to see the CEO of mozilla go now
this is a thousand dollars that he did
uh roughly five years ago i think a
thousand dollars i think it's a
significant amount of money and i think
you know when people always say put
money where your mouth is people vote
with their dollars so and also it's not
just that money it's also his lack of um
like retracting or even or the
statements supporting that donation even
years later right so we have no
indication that he doesn't still feel
that way uh but a lot has changed in
five years and it is possible to change
and it was only a thousand dollars so
was this a bit of an overreaction to
sort of he didn't get fired he stepped
down yeah i think he had the opportunity
to say you know what like it was 2008
things are different now i have evolved
my thoughts on gay man
and and you know what i shouldn't have
done that he had some opportunity to
kind of apologize yeah and he really
just kind of stood with it and said sir
so even if his thought having evolved
Russian should he should have the right
know but should someone be have the
right to be the CEO of a pretty public
company uh and not before gay marriage I
think it's an interesting question i
guess maybe the answer is probably yes
but i think it's i don't think it's
smart business sense i get will marvel
obviously yeah totally i means you know
if I didn't like you know green people I
wouldn't say it because likely some of
my customers are green yeah i mean like
it just it just shuts him out thank you
so yeah it was just like such a
distraction that he kind of had to if
they were gonna move forward at all in a
new year he kind of had to step down
what do you guys think about the the
hypocrisy of the okcupid guy so he bans
the mozilla you know explorer or
whatever on for his site but it turns
out that he has donated to some things
that he may not be so proud of too but i
think the difference being that since
this is like years and years later he
has had the opportunity to say you know
i supported this then I don't support it
now and so I think people can kind of
make that differentiation yeah are
either one of you guys fans of urban
outfitters by any chance I like urban
outfitters yeah i think that t-shirt
might be it is it not it's not you need
to take it off guys I trust you i know
you gladly will take it off have a look
yeah because the owner the president and
founder of Urban Outfitters has donated
money to Rick Santorum's campaign he
said some other anti gay stuff so it is
weird how we sort of pick and choose who
we decided to rail against what we hear
that on YouTube all the time if we wear
something that is from urban outfitters
and people recognize that people will
email me and be like you wore that shirt
it's from urban outfitters I can't
believe you're supporting this so what's
your personal policy on that so you do
where urban outfitters despite knowing
that I mean I full disclosure I have
plenty of urban affairs yeah yeah yeah I
mean I didn't realize when I bought the
shirt that I was you know look on the
internet you can't win no matter what
you do and and you can try to tread as
you can you could donate a million
dollars to schools in Africa and people
will email you and say you know what
there's a lot of work that needs to be
at home when you just can't win right
right all right so with every so since
we're winning the war
are here right since we're winning this
game or its I mean we're getting a
marriage in every state every couple
weeks some activist judge does something
we get some more gay marriage up doing
in a weird way that the gay community
should somehow figure out a way to be a
little more gracious somehow for these
people should we figured not gracious
exactly but we figure out a way to be a
little more open to these people that
maybe did things five years ago that
whether they're proud of it or not I
don't putting I know it's putting it on
us which i think is sort of difficult
cuz we still don't have full equality
but I think there's something to that
that there's these people holding on to
something that they're losing and maybe
we should somehow figure out a way to
embrace them a little bit more instead
of everyone just fighting all that I
gave you a lot to work with yeah yeah I
think the question that people are
trying to ask is even if you felt this
way have your thought processes evolved
do you feel this way now and that's
giving people that's giving people who
are in positions of power and influence
on the public eye the opportunity to say
either yes or no and you know we've all
we all grow and learn I'm not the same
person that I was five years ago and and
so people are wanting to see where their
leader stand today and so I think the
leaders who are not being as tactful as
they should be are getting a little bit
of blowback yeah you know that yeah I am
I don't care so much what someone said
ten years ago and then the whole thing
with the gay rights movement is that
we're hoping to change hearts and minds
and when we do that with someone we
can't hold that against them that that
their opinion is now different and and I
think that's a great thing if they still
think that I shouldn't get married I
won't I will not have compassion no
problem yeah